resolution the united kingdom said a
security council meeting on tuesday
would focus on bucha a mid-growing
outcry over alleged atrocities there
it'll be the first opportunity the
security council has had to discuss the
images that we've seen in brucha which
you've heard widely over the weekend
described both as war crimes and as
genocide so we really are
facing the true reality of the appalling
russian invasion of ukraine but that
wasn't soon enough for the russian
ambassador who called his own press
conference and accused ukraine of
staging images of dead civilians he
pointed to social media video of bucha's
mayor smiling at the announcement of
russia's troop withdrawal said to be
shot on march 31st a day after russians
pulled out in it there is no mention of
dead civilians
from the very beginning it has been
clear that this
is nothing else but yet another stage
provocation
aimed at discrediting and dehumanizing
of the russian military and leveling
political oppression or pressure on
russia his claims however were seemingly
undermined by a new york times analysis
of satellite images said to show the
bodies present before russian troops
withdrew
ukraine has again called for an
independent investigation
this is why
myself and my fellow parliamentarians we
did everything possible and impossible
to get international journalists to
bucha
at the uh first days of liberation so it
would be not us saying what happened
there but it will be representatives of
all the media all over the world
respectable journalists war journalists
who seen things and who would say what
they have seen in bucha
meanwhile the u.s ambassador called
russia's presence on the human rights
council a farce and said she would
introduce a resolution to the general
assembly to suspend them
u.n officials have called the images
from bucha shocking and horrifying
secretary general antonio guterres and
the high commissioner for human rights
michelle bachelet have each called for
independent investigations guterres will
address the security council on tuesday
as will ukrainian president vladimir
zelensky kristin salumi al jazeera the
united nations